olá a todos é eu vi e ouvi dizer a todos
que realmente eu garantir assim no fim
e pra fechar essa jornada que leva
história viva e forma está na vida
realmente amor fosse obrigado pra mim e
viu de viver que precisavam considerar
uma minha volta é enfim é não gostar os
fãs avaliados é e mas querem introduzir
também eu acho que encontrei um caminho
ou seja eu não gosto mas são aquelas
pessoas que têm muita consciência tubo e
gol da vitória e tentar passar mensagens
positivas
ou seja isso já se tem alguma coisa que
vocês que eu gosto de fazer
claro que tem que haver alguma coisa
jogar é um interesse muito sobre as
coisas vão gostar a falar das coisas é
ver uma forma quase sem saber o gosto um
tanto fletir ou seja já estou com um
consolo to love e realmente estava
vai por mim a pensar eu fui o
espermatozóide icsi gol mais rápido hoje
a frase eu acho que devemos pensar nisso
e acho que acima de tudo devemos pensar
que somos sempre capazes
é gente é e nunca pensei estar aqui hoje
e mesmo sítio aqui agora é falar assim
convosco
porque eu acho que com 16 anos nunca
pensou em fazer uma coisa nesse quando
vivemos quer se sair com os amigos andar
dessas coisas é e eu não eu criei uma fã
pela forma mais complicada quer ter sua
idade vem que eu vi que não gostei da
nossa vida porque eu acho que eu sou um
caso um carro não muito
sim agora e e acho que no sonho
o chanceler da forma e não me importo de
luca um caminho fácil e nem mesmo o
mundo e pensar que eu acho que tudo isto
que eu acho que o fato de israel não
quer dizer que está tudo paralisado
porque lá estava o tio sempre a ver com
a evolução muito complicados e realmente
e japão o japão realmente são muito
complicados e realmente não poderia ter
aceitado mas é complicado pra estão
usando é e eu tenho uma visão ambiciosa
a gente que sem oxigenação no branco o
parto
eis caso o caso é produzir scirocco e
com vocês vim e tem que andar sempre com
o under-linux câmbio e nas prateleiras
o outro pm não sabe falar pra vocês não
têm nenhuma lei eu estou com tanta
naturalidade ou seja eu acho que todos
nós temos que ver o lado positivo eo
regulamento só isto um capítulo à suíte
gostaram das jóias com pessoas e gosto
muito de falar sobre por exemplo é falar
do brasil israel com um falar convosco
não é uma coisa que quem não gostou cg
gosto falar até porque eu acho que
ninguém nasce ensinado os ensinamentos
são os dados ao longo da vida e acho que
nós temos que aprender com esses
ensinamentos ou seja ninguém ensina nós
temos que ensinar essa pessoa está
informada sobre o mundo e é tiro - o rio
ave que o mundo e são várias realidades
ou seja o assunto
sou só eu posso volto a companhia está
no assunto complicado da mesma forma
porém em pratos limpos
uma confusão porque esta chegou um ponto
que também sabem que onde foi mais
começava vencerá o caso e acho que foi
um cabo e por isso está nessa condição
que eu não tenho problemas uns com isso
porque fui eu acho que uma das crianças
dada
a herança estão a vida e acho que nem
são action eu uma herança foi lançado um
chavo e vai ser sempre essa é uma
autoridade ea forma de ver as coisas do
mundo e também em cara de criança uma
forma de vida sorri porque eu acho que
não há não há melhor forma de v
queremos alcançar seus objetivos e
queremos ultrapassar o os sacos é que
não seja com o silêncio e eu tenho
sempre um sorriso no rosto
claro que não é um evento que sempre sai
com com o sorriso seja de que maneira
for
depois é isso aí sim eu acho que vocês
pensarem em mim nós nós temos sempre de
mim assim é e eu sei disso a minha venda
ver que eu tenho escrito negócios que
nós todos fazemos as coisas e temos que
o encontro teve já não podemos sonhar
nada temos que ser tipo um salvado assim
todos os direitos e de hoje e não cola
vira uma diferença que há mais crianças
empresa nós achamos estranho e eu acho
que não é assim
eu acho que todos nós temos é nossas
novas enfrenta além do que já há algumas
diferenças que se a ação é site com um
normais ea outras 1 casa enfrenta física
no meu caso